[Música]
el presidente francés emmanuel macrón le
ganó la reelección a marín le peña estar
al frente del país durante otro período
el mandatario que reconoció que muchos
votos no fueron de adhesión sino contra
la ultraderechista prometió un nuevo
quinquenio de renovación de sus
políticas
al cumplirse dos meses de la invasión
rusa sobre ucrania el presidente con los
dimensiones que se reunió en kiev con
los secretarios de estado de defensa de
eeuu mientras el mandatario pide a
washington armamento más potente su
gobierno busca dialogar con moscú sobre
mariupol
con una abrumadora mayoría del congreso
del salvador aprobó esta noche prorrogar
el régimen de excepción solicitado por
el presidente nadie bukele la medida
está en vigor desde el 27 de marzo y
permite al gobierno realizar detenciones
sin órdenes judiciales en medio de su
lucha contra las pandillas tenemos
reportes de nuestro corresponsal en
centroamérica
actualizamos las noticias en france 24
yo soy juan pupiales gracias por
permanecer con nosotros el manuel macrón
es el ganador del balotaje en las
elecciones presidenciales de francia y
estará otros 5 años en el cargo después
de vencer a la ultraderechista marine
lepén con más del 90 por ciento de las
mesas escrutadas se impuso con el 58
punto 54 por ciento de los votos frente
al 41 46 por ciento del epen macrón es
el primer presidente reelecto desde el
2002 mientras que su rival consiguió el
mejor resultado electoral en la historia
para la ultraderecha emanuel mccrone se
queda en el elíseo
el escrutinio da como ganador al actual
presidente sobre su rival la
ultraderechista marine lepén con 58
puntos 54 por ciento se impuso en las
presidenciales aunque ganó el resultado
fue menor al de la contienda de 2017
cuando también se enfrentó al epp en su
discurso de victoria desde el campo de
marte anunció que buscará la unión de la
francia polarizada además reconoció que
no todos sus votos fueron de adhesión a
sus políticas sino de oposición a él
todos juntos tendremos que trabajar por
esa unidad que será la única que nos
permitirá vivir más felices y enfrentar
los retos que nos esperan
los años que vienen no serán tranquilos
con toda seguridad pero sí serán años
históricos y todos juntos sabremos
escribirlos para nuestras generaciones
pese a su holgada victoria es consciente
de las críticas a su gobierno crisis
como las manifestaciones de los chalecos
amarillos el manejo de la pandemia y la
guerra en ucrania por eso anunció un
cambio de este próximo quinquenio
por todo esto quiero junto a todos
ustedes afrontar los próximos cinco años
esta nueva era no será la continuidad
del mandato que acaba de terminar
sino la invención colectiva de un nuevo
método para cinco años que serán mejores
al servicio de nuestro país y de nuestra
juventud de los corazones
[Aplausos]
marine le pen recibió el 41 46 %
interpretó los resultados como una
victoria el resultado de esta noche
representa en sí mismo de todas maneras
una victoria sorprendente
esta francia tan olvidada nosotros no la
olvidaremos
estamos más determinados que nunca y
nuestra voluntad de ayudar a los
franceses es aún mayor además de
anunciar que sería oposición de macrón
llamó a votar masivamente las
legislativas para hacerse con el
parlamento esta noche lanzamos la gran
batalla electoral de las legislativas
[Aplausos]
librar esta batalla al lado del señor
lay con todos los que tuvieron la
valentía de oponerse al señor marco en
la segunda vuelta la extrema derecha
tuvo una votación sin precedentes en
estas elecciones aunque la abstención de
28 2 % fue la más alta desde la segunda
vuelta presidencial de 1969
dejamos a un lado las elecciones
francesas y hablamos de la invasión rusa
en ucrania que este domingo cumplió dos
meses la administración de volodymyr
selenski dijo que el presidente
ucraniano se reunió con el secretario de
estado de eeuu estaban feni blinken con
el jefe de defensa de lloyd austin en
kiev el encuentro del cual no se conocen
detalles y que no ha sido confirmado por
la casa blanca supondría la visita de
más alto rango por parte de washington a
este país y el comienzo de la guerra en
los últimos días selenski ha insistido
en sus llamados para que la unión
americana de esa corriente con un
armamento de mayor capacidad para hacer
frente a las tropas rusas
ucrania y rusia celebraron este domingo
la pascua ortodoxa pero bajo condiciones
muy diferentes a por ella ciudad del sur
ucraniano a pocos kilómetros de las
tropas de moscú vivió la fiesta bajo el
temor de nuevos ataques
nuestras enviadas especiales y leticia
álvarez irene sabios se desplazaron
hasta el lugar y nos cuentan cómo
transcurrió una de las fechas más
importantes para los ortodoxos en medio
de una guerra
tatiana jaroslav celebran en su casa de
zamorilla la pascua ortodoxa en plena
guerra esta familia vive a tan sólo 50
km de las tropas rusas desde que empezó
la guerra se resguardan cuando oyen el
sonido de las sirenas temen acudir a la
iglesia después de los últimos ataques
de rusia cuando escuchamos que rusia
habla de provocaciones entendemos que
ellos un lugar han las noticias de ayer
de lo que hicieron en odessa muchas
personas murieron para que ellos solo
bombardean con cohetes edificios como
éste venden line wendy's hoy es día de
celebración de juntarse con toda la
familia pero va por ella más de la mitad
de la población ha dejado sus hogares y
esta ceremonia se vive con inquietud son
vulneradas na no tributó tout sigue
cerrando me gustaría sentir alegría pero
no puedo evitar sentir inquietud no me
puedo lavar la cabeza porque cuando voy
al baño suena una alarma y tendré que
correr con la cabeza mojada que se me
cruza the wind y shake
y cuando preparó la comida me levanto a
las cinco y las seis de la mañana
empezarán las alarmas añádanse nets 6
sin embargo en la iglesia ortodoxa
ucraniana des beato poco ves que la
guerra no ha paralizado la celebración
de la resurrección de jesús a pesar de
las amenazas muchos ciudadanos han
decidido venir aquí a la principal
iglesia ortodoxa de zamorilla para
celebrar la pascua ortodoxa
svitlana es profesora en un colegio de
zamorilla y reza cada noche para que su
ciudad no termine como la martirizada
mariupol
y esto después de chiquitas tengo fe en
que dios nos protegerá que ningún misil
caerá en nuestra tierra de sabor' y aquí
están
y
es que la virgen de poco ha cubierto con
un manto de la polilla y estaremos a
salvo de quien ha creado para que nos
apoye
sin esperanza de una paz cercana los que
se quedan rezan porque la invasión rusa
termine pronto
el congreso del salvador aprobó en una
plenaria extraordinaria una prórroga de
un mes del régimen decepción que rige en
este país desde el 27 de marzo y cuya
extensión solicitó del presidente nadie
bukele para la lucha contra las
pandillas el legislativo dio su luz
verde con 67 votos a favor así las cosas
de gobierno seguirá teniendo la
capacidad de realizar detenciones sin
órdenes judiciales e intervenir las
telecomunicaciones detalles desde
antigua guatemala con nuestro
corresponsal en centroamérica andrés
suárez
con 67 votos a favor 5 en contra y 3
abstenciones la asamblea legislativa de
el salvador aprobó en la noche de este
domingo y por mayoría la prórroga de 30
días del estado de excepción propuesto
por el presidente nadie bukele en su
denominada guerra contra las pandillas
la sesión estuvo marcada por la
intervención de los diputados que en su
mayoría aprueban y además apoyan las
medidas que el presidente
centroamericano ha tomado en la
persecución y captura de los más de
16.000 pandilleros en el término de un
mes pero también tuvieron eco las voces
disidentes de la oposición que
denunciaron vejámenes violaciones de
derechos humanos la detención arbitraria
de centenares de personas solamente por
tener tatuajes en su piel y además la
muerte de varios de los pandilleros
durante los arrestos de esta manera se
aplaza por un mes el estado de excepción
que suprime en este país
centroamericanos las libertades y
constitucionales y amplía y faculta a la
policía para perseguir y capturar a la
mayor cantidad de pandilleros posibles a
quienes se les atribuye la ola de
violencia que dejó en el mes de marzo
más de 80 asesinados en tan solo tres
días según el gobierno de buque le es
necesario esta extensión del estado de
excepción porque de los 70.000 maderos
que se registran en las cuentas
oficiales del gobierno de buques ya hay
32 mil en las cárceles pero quedan más
de la mitad en libertad
terminamos esta emisión en las calles de
japón con el desfile del día del orgullo
gay miles marcharon por el distrito de
shibuya en una celebración de su
identidad y para defender una sociedad
sin discriminación
con esas imágenes despedimos esta
emisión informativa en 324 pero quédense
porque la información continua
[Música]